le soir après le travail audrey aubert
pas souvent une heure à s'entraîner avec
son fils beat son bracelet intelligent
sur le bras elle suit en direct
l'évolution de sa forme physique
facebook que je cours je capable de voir
un peu mon battement cardiaque
le temps que j'ai couru le nom de
calories mais pas question de
transmettre ces données à une compagnie
d'assurance c'était quelqu'un de super
en forme qui fait vraiment attention à
ton corps piqué toujours ce qui est
toujours été en forme je peux voir que
ça peut être avantageux moi
personnellement je me sentirais pas à
l'aise de voir ma compagnie d'assurance
de savoir au moins grande synthe hier a
décidé de se mettre les pieds sur le
pauvre pendant un mois entier et
pourtant si ce que propose plusieurs
compagnies d'assurance comme manuvie
l'assureur fournit aux clients
intéressés un bracelet intelligent qui
permet d'enregistrer des données comme
l'y minutes d'activité physique ou les
pots effectués dans une journée
les clients indiquent aussi s'ils vont
alors rendez vous annuel chez le médecin
ou chez le dentiste plus ils ont de
bonnes habitudes plus les économies sur
la prime d'assurance vie avec un
programme comme celui-là ce qu'on
cherche à faire c'est à contrôler mieux
les coûts humains de santé donc de faire
en sorte que les gens soient en santé
saviez augmenter la productivité saviez
augmenter l'engagement d'entreprises
un argument contesté par ce professeur
de droit le vrai avantage des lits pour
les compagnies d'assurance à terme
nécessairement ces informations là c'est
pas pour le bien commun les compagnies
d'assurance les collectes c'est pour
être capable de fixer véritablement le
risque que représentent les assurer la
participation programme de manuvie est
volontaire mais selon cet expert ceux
qui y prennent part doivent être
vigilants par le rythme de respiration
par exemple on peut révéler des
conditions préexistantes en ce qui
concerne notre état de santé dont on
n'est même pas conscients et qu'ils
peuvent à terme nous rendre non
assurables ou encore faire exploser
notre prime d'assurance manuvie assure
que ce n'est pas le cas
et qu'on soit pour ou contre ce genre de
programme
d'après houdré il faut surtout trouver
une façon de se motiver motivation doit
venir de toi-même mais des fois en
payant ça peut donner un coup de main un
coup de main oui mais pour elle il y a
des limites à ce qu'une compagnie
d'assurance peut faire pour nous aider à
tenir nos résolutions ici laurence
partie radio canada